[Music]
hello and welcome back to the road of
2000 as always my name is national
master Caleb bendy and I will be your
driver on this journey so last weekend I
actually had the pleasure of doing some
more commentary over another tournament
and this was the tournament which was
the inaugural Midwest Collegiate Chess
Championships so of course more and more
schools in the Midwest now developing
some very strong chess teams with some
world-class players and this was where
they all battled it out this year yeah
the event was actually hosted by the
Mizzou University so we were over in
Columbus Missouri Columbia not Columbus
Columbia Missouri so yeah I had a great
time doing commentary over the event and
there was some very interesting games
played as well as some world-class
players so why don't we just jump in and
take a look at what what went on so this
game was played between Dimitri
Gordievsky who is board two from Mizzou
and daro spirits who I believe is board
one for the st. Louis University team
daro actually ended up winning the
entire event and this game was pretty
key in securing that victory I believe
this was round three and this was one of
the more impressive games the
tournament's my eyes at least if I had
to pick one favorite game I think it
would be this one so white starts out
with Knight f3 which I've talked about a
little bit on the commentary if you guys
caught that it's one of the more
flexible first moves for white it's kind
of a waiting move it lets black choose
which line he wants to play and then
white will have a little bit more
information and will be able to choose
his line kind of in response to that in
this case Darrow plays d5 and after c-4
we have a true ready opening sometimes
you'll see players here they were kind
of joking about playing the ready with
Knight f3 and they'll switch with d4 and
transpose into some more normal Queens
gambit
type of structures but after c4 it's a
true ready and now the onus is on black
to the site if he will rise to White's
challenge and play this move d4 which in
this game black actually does rise to
the challenge so what do we think about
this position what catches your eye
first of all have you guys seen this
position before are you familiar with
the main ready yeah as with all things
in chess there are pluses and minuses to
having this pawn on d4 as you said one
weakness is that it might fall under
attack it might come under quick fire
from the white pieces but at the same
time it's going to be taking a lot of
central space trying to cramp the white
pieces so white tries to get an improved
version of what would be kind of a
benoni a Benoni style structure in in
with the reverse colors so white goes
ahead and plays the break b4 on move
three whereas the normal but no knees
you'll see black try to prepare this
move with a six sometimes Bishop d7 or
b8 and we're very hard to try to get b5
in one advantage of moving first is that
you know you get to do these things a
little bit quicker so white plays b4 and
then blacks next move is very very
interesting and very combative so what
moves might stick out to you if you were
playing black here what developing moves
would you be keeping an eye on
yeah knight c6 v6 maybe g6 would pop out
to you guys as we said this pawn is it's
gonna be the major weakness for black
and so black should be trying to find
ways to add some defenders to this pawn
the main way of doing that is to you
know get this pawn to e5 somehow and so
g6 is a common move white might play
Bishop b2 black might play Bishop beset
or Bishop g7 and you might get a 5 in
this type of type of structure in the
game daro tried a little bit more of an
ambitious version of this g6 plan rather
than playing g6 he wants to play g5 on
move 3 so this is pretty unorthodox so
creating a lot of weaknesses a lot of
light squares being weakening weekends
it's also kind of making a threat if if
white wants to take this pawn black is
going to expand in the center very very
quickly and black is not going to really
be missing this G pawn in the long run
just very quick expansion in the center
is blacks idea if white wants to just
develop normally kind of ignore this g5
move I can actually consider playing g4
and now this Knight is looking a little
bit short on squares and black will
continue developing and this pawn might
prove to actually be quite annoying to
deal with so why it's choice in the game
was actually this move h3 which has been
played before in this position but it's
not really my favorite it's kind of a
yeah this is this is the point to stop
the advance of the jeep on but it is
kind of just spending some time to
defend the g4 square but by no means you
know as white wears here white hasn't
done too much wrong besides try to play
the benoni but you can forgive them for
that and now black plays h6 securing his
pawn
well you wouldn't you would be surprised
so the advantage of having a central
majority like this where you have a lot
of space in the center is that you can
usually castle them on the Kings side
like this because your opponent in this
case is is trying to find space on the
Queen side so the Kings side should be
reasonably safe for for black you see
both players just develop normally like
I said black needs to support this pawn
he pushes this pawn to e5 to do so now
Bishop g2 Knight East seven castles
castles Knight bTW - and ninety six and
this is kind of a we're starting to
leave the opening phase now White has
gotten pretty much developed Castle Otis
King he just needs to find something to
do with this Bishop and black is still
sorting out some some of these pieces on
the Queen side so with this position in
mines how do you think this game is
going to continue what are the plans
going to be for either side anyway let's
start with the the white pieces what is
white going to be doing over the next
few moves
yes so how do you activate these pieces
how can we do it a four is a great idea
and this is totally in line with White's
plan white wants to push these pawns
forward on the queenside and which will
give this bishop some open diagonals
this work will be nicely placed
supporting the advances as well as he's
always working to improve this bishop on
g2 I've mentioned this before but in a
lot of openings where white fee and head
owes this Bishop and becomes his main
piece he really wants to activate this
thing on the long diagonal and it's
gonna be no different here
so yeah there's pressure along this lung
diagonals what I was saying and the
spawns gonna come forward and whites
going to try to break things down on the
queenside that's how he wants to win so
white plays Knight b3 bringing another
piece over to here also preventing some
ideas for black of using the c5 square
later on if this pawn pushes to be five
tonight b3 is a very natural move so now
let's think for the black side whatever
blacks plan is going to be well what is
black going to do while white is playing
on the Queen side well you meet him on
the Queen side and try to kind of shut
down White's play will you play in the
center or will he go for some kind of
King side attack there's some
combination of these let's try and just
think of some eventual pawn break some
eventual moves that black wants to do
okay so the thing about this structure
is whenever black gets close to actually
threatening h3 white is happy to play
King age - and now it's tough to add
another attacker to this square black or
white does have to be a little bit
careful it'd be a mistake for example to
play something like a four and allow
maybe something some idea with g4 I
don't know if it's good in this
particular position
right so there's there some ideas here
of threatening the h3 pawn like this but
that's not really a plan to open things
up so what is black going to actually
want to do here
so someone in you - so when you say
playing the center you're talking about
this efore break right eventually you
said Ricky eight but you're you want to
eventually push this pawn and that's
definitely one idea but the problem with
pushing this pawn for it is you're
always going to be leaving this D pawn
behind so this is definitely one plan
that that black can kind of go for here
is playing a four but you have to have
quite a lot of support for it so someone
in YouTube also mentioned f5 and this is
going to eventually be blacks break he
does want to play f5 but the thing is
he's not sure if he's playing e4 he's
not sure if he's playing f4 and he's
actually not sure if he's playing g4 or
even age five and h4 these are all
different moves that black is going to
be considering these are different ways
to break down the white camp and that's
that's what makes this difficult it does
make the d5 square weak yes
so black doesn't actually play f5
immediately I'm just saying in the long
run
he's going to be playing f5 and things
like these breaks are all going to be on
blacks mind so the short of it is black
wants to play in the center and on the
Kings side but mainly his goal is going
to be a King side attack whether he
achieves that by breaking through the
center is kind of irrelevant it's just
whatever appears best on the board once
he gets to that position
so black plays Knight c6 using this
wrote to develop the knight there are
mousse-like b5 here from from white
kicking this night away now the night
comes to e7 it's supporting as you said
the square which might be eventually
weakened with f5 supporting f5 itself
and you can imagine if this Knight ever
leaves this square never jumps into some
other square this Knight can come in as
well
all right even into the f5 square so
white plays i-4 and black continues with
rook b8 he spends a move to get the rook
off the the long open diagonal and give
this best room a little bit more freedom
for the future plans white wastes no
time plays Bishop a3 and so as we said
White's playing on the Queen side and
black is playing on the Kings side and
kind of in the center and black comes up
with this move b6 which i think is
pretty important here if black doesn't
play b6 which maybe could have waited
the turn if you just like develops this
Bishop - you know let's let's say d7 now
after something like a 5 if you don't
play b6 here now White's going to play
b6 and the problem is yes you do went
upon for the moment but now this file is
half open this b-pawn is rather stuck on
on this b7 square and what's going to
find a lot of counter play so these six
is a nice idea for black to to slow down
White's play force them not to be able
to play this move b6 but rather just
keep things a little bit more locked
down and now we see a 5-4 might very
natural just wants to open the a file
still find counter play black plays
Bishop e6 white plays Knight FD to just
opening up this diagonal bringing more
pieces to the Queen side you see Queen
d7 you know after King age 2 like we
said attacking this pawn white needs to
defend it black plays f5 and white
starts repeating here because white was
feeling a little bit under under danger
I think so
we've kind of arrived at the position
where black is now going to start
deciding which of these pawn breaks is
the best one to play you can play efore
you can play f4 we can play g4 or you
can play something like h5 and H 4 so
blacks pieces are not perfectly set up
yet but which of these four breaks is
really looking like like the way to go
here if you're the black player which
one of these sticks out to you
what do you think Aditya which pawn
brick f4 so the way you have to think
about it is which what do each of these
pawn breaks give up whenever you push
upon forward you're leaving squares
behind and so you just have to determine
which squares are really important here
so let's say white plays Queen c2 now if
F for what squares are you leaving
behind and are they important right
the c-4 Square might actually get a
little bit annoying for you if you're
pushing this pawn to f4 quite so quickly
you know this Knight might come in to e4
and you're defending the Kings side and
you know white might be getting into
some trouble later on but you do improve
White's pieces quite a bit with f4 so
that one's not my favorite so besides f4
who thinks e four is the way to go
anybody well yeah
so immediately efore is impossible
because y can simply take it so e four
going to be a little bit difficult to
achieve that's not to say it's
impossible
you know black could try and prepare it
with like rook e8 try maneuver some
other pieces around
so yeah you like g4 and so what is the
idea if it simply plays h4 here what are
you going to do how do you eventually
win in the long run so yeah I mean you
can attack the h4 pawn but the G pawns
always going to defend it it's always
going to be there to defend it well I
mean how are you how are you going to
achieve that so yeah if you come here
immediately I can even play something
like King g1 maybe I'll take care first
take and king g1 win chief pawn still
gonna be defending it so you have to
understand what you're giving up with g4
what you're giving up with g4 is this h4
square you're not really giving up on f4
because you still have this pawn to
control it so you're giving up the idea
of having a pawn ever be able to attack
h4 and so what this means what you're
committing to with g4 is that if you
want to continue the attack you're gonna
have to sacrifice a piece on h4 more
than likely maybe you can finagle some
way to pin g3 but more than likely
so more than likely you're gonna have to
sacrifice a piece on g4 I'm not saying
that this is a bad thing as you said I
mean this night is also ready to come in
but you just have to understand this is
what you're willing to do if you play g4
so daro doesn't want to commit to g4
just yet he wants to make sure his
pieces are well coordinated and he's
ready to sacrifice a piece before he
actually plays g4 and that's why we
don't see him rush here he simply plays
this move rook f7 stepping out of this
pin and actually we've know so Queen c2
wasn't wasn't played in the game I'm
sorry Queen c2 was my example move yes
so we'll talk about the specifics in
just a second but the point is he's not
rushing things with g4 just yet he wants
to make sure he's ready before before
age 4 happens so Bishop c6 was was
White's choice and now actually black
has the option to give up an exchange
with Knight takes c6 and Pontic sand in
Queen takes this would actually be
pretty pretty favorable for black to do
but in the game black chose to keep
material equality with Queen d8 and now
Bishop g2 black repeated with Queen d7
once white tried to repeat again now if
black wanted to draw he could play Queen
d7 but daro ended up actually liking his
position here I think so he chose to
play on with your kev 7 the main idea is
just stepping out of this pin so now on
bishop c6 there's always going to be
Knight takes c6 and so now things are
getting pretty urgent here for for white
so you know that this g4 idea is coming
soon and then black is really going to
start you know sacrificing opening
things up on the Kings side and you're
gonna get checkmated unless you can
force him to draws attention back to the
Queen's side so in the game
Dmitri Gordievsky played Bishop b4 here
which is not my favorite move I don't
think it's his favorite move either
after
after seeing what happened in the game
he just wanted to open things up for his
rook and eventually capture capture and
bring the rook in but it's all just a
little bit too slow so what are some
faster ways of playing for white how can
we get countered play more more quickly
on this Queen side yeah see if I was a
great idea to consider but the the
counter also also happens bishops on a
three bishops on a three here so yes c5
is a good idea
but what I was saying is that you have
to consider the same things you're
considering over on the Kings side all
of these moves give up squares and c5 as
well is giving up some squares of course
what are those squares here yeah and the
b v square a little bit so you're gonna
start running into things like ninety
five and Knight c3 if you commit to c5
two too early so c5 not quite what we're
looking for here because it gets black
just too many opportunities to activate
its pieces there's also of course
immediate ideas of ticks and in ticks
now I don't think these these are quite
good here because there are things like
Knight takes and black spawns are a
little fractured but you do have to be
worried about this this be pawn as well
so not quite c5 how else can we find
activity for for white
so there are some ideas in the YouTube
chat they want to take on a six and I'm
assuming a takes P six then they want to
take on e7 and now they can bring the
rook into a7 yeah and this is what I was
actually thinking during the game that
Dmitry would go for something like this
and I I think what drew him away from
this was he thought this bishop was was
pretty nice on a3 and this knight on e7
wasn't so important for black but one
huge advantage to it is it's it's kind
of gaining time here
white wasted no time playing Bishop
before he takes black takes back and
already the the rook lands on the a7
Square and well yeah this file is never
in question
thanks to this Bishop on g2 it's always
going to be covered and now you can
start considering things like c5 and
these this is what's really going to
break the game open imagine like black
continues on on the Kings side over here
but now your counter play on the Queen
side is coming a little bit more quickly
and so I think that's what uh what white
really needed to do here is play with a
little bit more urgency because the
attack on the the Kings side is coming
quite quickly dart plays Bishop f6 like
I said he's aiming to eventually
sacrifice a piece on this h4 square so
he's preparing his pieces for it and the
best and the best place possible
yeah
so so a takes b6 a takes p6 was played
rook a6 comes in from white and then
this move was a little bit confusing to
me at first I didn't really understand
why put the reckon a 6-1 on a7 it's
attacking c7 but he just had some ideas
along this week 6th rank of forcing this
pawn off the board was something like
Knight c5 and then this work being able
to do to come in these were his ideas
but I think they were there a little bit
flawed although definitely white is
already in some danger here black
continues with h5 just advancing his
plan of playing this g4 move also eyeing
maybe maybe an h4 move as well but h4
just doesn't really rip open the Kings
side quite like g4 would yeah so Queen
c2 is played and now is the time to
strike says Darrell he's improved his
pieces to the optimal squares more or
less this rook can have its choice of
squares over here depending on what
happens next
the Queen's already well placed it
supports this long die ignored not long
diagonal just regular length diagonal
from d8 behind this night and daro says
okay I'll play g4 and white definitely
agreed here that after h4 White's not
going to be able to get away with this
now the white is committed to so many
missed so many weaknesses over here
black really has this pick of moves you
could sacrifice immediately but maybe
stronger is to play f4 now you don't
care so so much about this square you're
just going to take here and play stuff
like Knight f5 and you're really
crashing through on this square you can
see all of black's pieces aimed kind of
against this plan from from white and
it's just not really gonna work out
so white realizes he can't play h4
chooses H takes G instead black takes
back with the H pawn opening up this
h-file wait plays rec h1 anticipating
that the black rook will appear on the H
file and now how do you want to continue
with with black here what's the best way
to break down the rest of these
defenders around this white King and
open up some more files so f4 is
definitely one way to go about it you
really have two choices here f4 is one
choice what's what's the other choice
how can you open up more more files
around the king f4 is definitely one
option what's what's the second option
even if it's a sacrifice yeah I mean not
h4 is possible yeah white doesn't white
doesn't have to take it and even if
white does take it you're not you're not
really opening too many things you are
getting rid of this pawn but it's not
the only way yet someone in YouTube has
said efore and this is in fact the the
other choice here and II for was what
daro played in the game
f4 I think would be still a very
pleasant position for black I don't
think this is throwing away the
advantage or anything but it does like I
said give get white some squares and so
the way black has done it is actually an
idea that is used
I wouldn't say commonly but it is a very
nice idea for when you have a huge
advantage in the center and you're not
sure how you can you know advance it to
cause weaknesses without giving your
opponent squares and the way you can do
that is actually by sacrificing one of
your pawns so he plays efore first and
now after D takes e4 you'll notice and
all the lines where this pawn moves to
f4 suddenly the white knight cannot
appear on the e4 square anymore because
there's a pawn in the way and this this
was exactly Dara's choice D takes e4 and
now he breaks through with f4 and this
is the way that daro makes sure that the
white pieces do not have a path back to
the Kings side he plays before first
forcing white to capture and now that
White has captured this square is of no
use to him at all in the game things are
already looking pretty dire perhaps
dmitriy could have tried to survive with
something like king h1 but he's just
gonna be much worse
you couldn't do what so it this is the
idea before you give up the e4 square
you still have this pawn defending it
forcing white to take back with the pawn
and now f4 comes and this square cannot
be used so Demetri could try to survive
maybe with King g1 this is what the
computer wants to play he didn't try
this though and I think black is simply
winning anyways Dimitri went for Bishop
take c7 F takes G 3 was inserted F takes
G 3 and now Dara takes back with the
knight but everything's kind of winning
here I think he could take that back any
any of the 3 ways and now White's big
plan was Knight c5 this was why you put
the rook on a6 but it's simply not good
here it might be good if black had to
play some move like Bishop a6 now all of
a sudden white can play Knight d3 he's
blockading this pawn keeping things a
little bit more closed he's not really
concerned about black taking here
because now in tandem with the bishop
this pawn is going to be kind of a
monster but black has a much better move
here and that move is d3 so this is kind
of the inverse of the last idea that we
looked at here black plays efore to
force upon into his opponent's way and
now in this position he plays d3
sacrificing his own pawn to make room
for his own pieces and this was some
very nice a very nice positional or kind
of positional play from daro to make
sure his opponents can't find activity
and he can no matter the cost of the
pawns
so night takes D 3 was White's choice
and now simply Bishop d4 making use of
this newly freed square creating a
checkmating threat against the white
king and the end is near white plays
Bishop f3 the only move to really give
him
an escape square like of course is not
interested in taking this in fixing
white spawns and giving the White King
shelter
instead he chooses rook h7 King g2 rook
takes King takes and now Queen f8 and
all sorts of bad things are gonna happen
to this King King g2 was Dimitri's
choice Queen comes to h6 anyways Knight
f2 and now let's see if you guys can
find a pretty nice checkmate here know
pretty much everything wins for black
I'll give it to you from this position
there are a couple more moves I could
probably put on the board and before I
give away the idea but let's see if you
can find a forced checkmate for black
now that's not to say everything's gonna
be with check nothing of the sort but
it's a natural start and so now how
would white respond
well if you come to d1 this is checkmate
in one so you need this h3 flight square
so instead of coming to d1 white would
probably capture capture this pawn and
then can you find a checkmate from that
position is there anything anything for
black there yeah okay Queen g1 but now
White has this extra square so how can
we deliver the final check meaning blow
[Music]
no I'm a little confused
the line is Queen e3 Knight takes G for
Queen g1 King h3 yes and is there and
checkmate for black in that position
what can black do to finish off white
give you a hint it's a very nice idea to
bring the last piece that's farthest
away from the attack into the action
yes King g7 and this rook comes in to
deliver the final checkmating blow and
this is exactly how the game transpired
Queen III tonight takes g4 Queen g1
check King h3 and after King g7 forcing
resignation from Dmitri Gordievsky this
game ended here there's no way to stop
this era coming to H a just checkmating
in this white King so a very nice idea
from Dara here to finish this game off
with a blast those key moves I wanted to
look at though earlier on in the game we
saw this idea of white playing without
enough urgency black's ideas on the
Kings side are coming very very quickly
and so white needs to play right now on
inside in order to make significant
threats yeah the point is black has
urgent threats on the Kings side in just
a few short moves once g4 does appear on
the board and black is ready for it the
white king is going to be facing danger
very very quickly
so this means why it doesn't really have
time to play things like Bishop b4 you
have to play a little bit more quickly
whether that be with Bishop b4 or
something like Queen c2 going for c5
immediately sorry of course that would
not be Bishop b4 whether that be
something like Queen c2 or a takes b6
and Bishop takes a 7
bringing the rook and immediately you
just have to do something more quickly
than then white really did here Bishop
b4 was the first kind of big mistake and
now the nice ideas I wanted to go over
once again for black choosing the pawn
break based on which squares it gives up
so he prepared for these dark squares
and that g4 gives up and since white was
unable to make use of those he was
forced to open up file number 1 in front
of his King and then this nice idea with
E for taking away the other weak squares
created by pushing these pawns so rather
than f4 immediately giving white this
nice square on e4 to help defend efore
first forcing upon to that square and
now after f4 things are opening up and
the white pieces are still helpless to
defend
yeah yeah the point is white didn't have
enough time to make his threats on the
queenside urgent so he ended up half
committing to the queenside and then
have him to give up and come back to the
Kings side but it was already too late
to stop Black's attack and that's why
this game went to daro spirits I think
this was the nicest game of the
tournament
darah really played this game well
showed a lot of understanding especially
this movie for I found to be very very
nice from daro and so well deserved
victory well-deserved tournament victory
as well he did end up winning this
tournament he scored 4 out of 5 in the
classical portion and then defeated his
teammate Nicholas Theodore who on
tiebreaks so he drew two games and won
three to get to that score and speaking
of Nicholas Theodore I didn't think it'd
be fair to him to leave him out of all
the fun and so this was his nice game
also against Dimitri Gordievsky to meet
you're getting a little bit picked on
tonight but but that's okay I do want to
get through this game and take a quick
look at one more so I'm gonna go through
this one a little bit more quickly
it was a Kings Indian defense and white
played this idea with h3 so some of you
might be familiar with the classical
Kings Indian I've done a couple lectures
on this where black plays in in the
center like this he 596 and the idea is
eventually black wants to break through
with f5 and f4 and come checkmate come
checkmate white but all of his ideas are
really starting with this f5 move and so
what we see from whites opening here
with h3 he's already kind of
telegraphing that is going to be
fighting for this at five square we see
after castles it should be three knight
a six
g4 this is White's big idea he's locking
down in this f5 square making it so that
blacks ideas of f5 are not going to be
quite so easy to achieve and might in
fact end up weakening his own King more
than whites you know why it might not
commit to castling quite so quickly you
might use the
gee file might launch his own attack on
the kingside so there are a lot of plans
here this plan does not make the most
sense in this structure it makes a lot
more sense into Puetz in this case
though where we usually see black
breaking in the center with E 5 this
Bishop actually does not become a very
important piece once the center is
closed with E 5 so black understood in
this game that F 5 wasn't going to be
the way for him to gain counter plan so
instead he chooses Knight a6 and starts
to play on the queenside
92 from White Knight c7 and Bishop g2 b5
is played d5 is why it's choice now we
see C takes D C takes D and let me ask
you another question here so what is
black going to be doing in this game
what is his plan going to be is he going
to eventually challenge White's claim to
the King site something like h5 forcing
these pawns off the light squares going
to eventually in fact place something
like f5 still challenging right on the
Kings side or is he going to play on the
Queen side somehow somehow find play
over here what do you think
yes so the C file why it can get to it
first but where is black going to play
and what are his intentions so what does
what does that mean what does he what is
he doing I mean you can control the dark
squares he's already controlling a lot
of dark squares but how does this
translate into a plan of action
what are his piece is going to be doing
how does he activate let's talk about
each piece specifically what is this
bishops future where do you want this
guy to go now for the moment you can
only go to d7 well you want to
eventually have a pretty coherent plan
with your pieces you want to find some
way to activate your pieces but still
have them working towards at least the
same side of the board the same kind of
common goal and you want them all to be
serving some kind of purpose so how do
you make these pieces all make sense
together for for black how can you do it
it's a very difficult question and when
I was doing commentary over this game I
didn't really see what black was going
to do and I was you know kind of tight
talking up White's position I thought
white was doing great here but actually
Dimitri had a pretty coherent plan going
on there are some people in the YouTube
chat with some very nice ideas saying
things like b5 or a 5 and they want to
put this Bishop on a6 which makes a
great deal of sense so you can kind of
imagine a coherent plan kind of forming
if black is playing on the queenside
will say and he pushes these pawns
forward he can activate his pj's Bishop
on the side of the board he can
eventually push something like b4
activate his knight coming into the
center on this side of the board this
night might come back to d7 and then to
c5 and this Bishop is going to be locked
to the Kings side but I can still serve
an important purpose in controlling this
slightly weakened Square on d4 for white
so this is how his minor pieces can kind
of all work together in tandem and this
is really important in pretty much any
opening you have to have at least some
plan of how you're going to put your
pieces to work doing the same thing for
the same side of the board with the same
purpose and so this was blacks plan here
and so actually I actually looking back
quite like blacks position I think he's
doing pretty nicely here because he has
this coherent plan which is going to be
pretty easy to follow and then in the
meantime White's plan is a little bit
less obvious there are downsides to
pushing things like f4 and actually
trying to checkmate black and it's a
little more difficult to see how this
Bishop is going to make sense with the
rest of these pieces so a 5 was black's
choice and after Knight g3 black just
continues with b5 he immediately is
gaining the space on the Queen side
making room for his pieces white castles
and Bishop a6 why wait around he
activates this bishop and now we'll see
b4 and these things are all going to
start coming on the board quite quite
quickly
rookie one for white and you can kind of
see that white is starting to falter a
little bit you know yes he has to play
moves like rookie one he's going to
bring this Bishop back to f1 likely to
just try and challenge what is now one
of blacks most powerful pieces and in
the meantime he's not making any
progress on the Kings side so what black
did in his opening I think was actually
very very impressive because he found a
plan for himself while his opponent
didn't really have much to do
Queen B ate was Dimitri's choice it's a
very interesting idea he wants to
activate this rook but he also wants to
commit as Queen to the Queen side so
rather than play move like Queen d7
which would serve largely the same
purpose Queen b8 this Queen already
influences the Queen side and still make
space for the rook rook c1 is why it's
choice and black continues with Knight
d7 so like I said and this bishop
controls d4 this Knight comes back to d7
eyeing more squares on the Queen side
and blacks pieces have finally started
to make sense and so I was actually very
very impressed with the way that Dmitri
was playing this game I thought he was
simply out playing his international
master opponent Nikolas Theodora but
we'll see things do start to eventually
go wrong for him
Bishop f1 was White's choice rook c8
black commits all of his pieces to the
Queen's side and you see white as kind
of left's a little bit haphazard here
this night on g3 wants to play in the
Kings side this Queen might want to come
to the Kings side this rook is staring
at his own pawn White has one rook on an
open C file and this Knight seems to be
committed to the Queen side he's kind of
kind of scatterbrained which is why I
think black was was doing quite nicely
here a4 is White's choice and black
wants to break it open on the side where
he's stronger so he does not play a move
like b4 which invites things to be a
little bit more closed on the Queen side
rather B takes a 4 opening things up
giving his pieces more open files more
open diagonals
Knight takes a four from white and you
see that this night has been kind of
completely sidelined this Bishop
captures the rook captures back and now
Knight b5 and you see this last piece
for black finally starting to make some
sense it's controlling this d4 square
indirectly allowing this Knight
- perhaps plant itself here Queen d3 is
White's choice Knight d4 from black rook
takes Queen takes rook c1 simply Queen
d8 from black just keeping an eye on
this side of the board as well as
controlling these entry squares King g2
is White's choice black plays this move
h6 just controlling some more dark
squares and after nightly - from white
black makes a threat with Queen f6
coming into f3 and taking this Knight
and let's talk about this position here
so Queen f6 was dimitris choice which is
actually it turns out to be a fine move
but I think he's starting to lose sight
of his plan here he got all this play on
the Queen side and now he starts to
divert his pieces back to the Kings side
which I don't think makes the most sense
here so what would you play if you were
black here what would you be thinking
about first of all I want to point out
it's like kind of passes which is a fine
thing to do this is not really going to
be a huge threat from white just yet
black is going to place something like
g5 keeping an eye on this square and now
after let's just say rook c2 or
something this nights gonna come in to
e5 and be a very powerful piece so I
don't think blacks should be too
concerned about Knight takes Knight
takes d4 just yet
yes so how can we activate our pieces to
play against this backward beep on but
more importantly we want to play against
this beep on but we also want to play
against this night on a floor it's been
very sidelined it's in a horrible square
and so how can we play against against
the night here yeah moves like rook b8
are what really black needs to be
looking at here I think this is the main
idea for black in this position coming
into be for supporting the center
putting pressure on this pawn and I
think if black had played rook b8 and
the game continued like this with black
on the Queen side I think Dmitry might
have actually been able to win this game
that's not to say he's better in this
position but I think his play would be a
little bit more natural than than
White's here and so it'd be kind of
tough to keep playing the best moose if
you are the white player here
yeah there's a coherent plan on the
queenside for black and this is this is
really the way black should be should be
playing after Queen f6 though white
plays Bishop d2 the idea being its Queen
now controls f3 and here's where Dmitry
really made his big mistake after Bishop
d2 like simply has to come back to d8
keep an eye on this c7 square not allow
the white rook to infiltrate instead
though we see Queen h4 and I do want to
mention after Queen d8 wait really has
no better than Bishop back to e3 and we
might have seen a repetition here but
Dmitry wanted a bit more he plays Queen
h4 instead allowing this work to come
into c7 and now all of a sudden with
this Queen sidelined over on h4 things
have really started to go wrong for for
black we see this Knight come in to f6
his Queens looking even more trapped now
now Knight takes d4 he takes d4 Bishop
f4 White has opened up access to this
weak D pawn and forcing moves like 98
from black and so what was once a very
nice position logical position for all
of blacks pieces black is now the one
looking a bit scattered and with none of
these pieces really working together
towards any kind of coherent plan rook
d7 rook b8 Bishop g3 the Queen comes
back to f6 and white simply expands on
the Kings side now and these pieces are
actually starting to work together rook
oh I plus press the zero key big mistake
will come back here
h4 rook d8 is black's choice trying to
get rid of one of these attackers but
rook b7 and things have gone horribly
wrong here
even the knight joins the party for
white and all of his pieces make sense
Black has gone passive and after Bishop
e5 black actually threw in the towel
here
of course there are tactics with with
this f4 move to look out for and things
are just going very very poorly for
black and this game is going to be over
pretty soon yeah that's that's the main
thing is black did this thing where he's
kind of switched sides of the board and
it made his pieces just scattered and it
allowed white into the game yeah he just
had to commit more to the Queen side the
Queen side side of things and I think
black could have had a very nice
position but instead we see this game
end and I think I misspoke on the tactic
you might start with 97 forcing this
Queen somewhere awkward if you go here
there's a check if you go to g7 now f4
might come and this Bishop is in fact
totally trapped so some tactics to end
the game forced a black to resign and
like I said the main idea of this game
black had a very very nice position
somewhere around this this area might be
594 very good moves and now once he
switches sides of the board this move
Queen d8 I already I'm a little
suspicious of but it's fine and now
especially with Queen f6 I think this is
just going in the wrong direction
and like I said Queen h4 kind of the the
biggest mistake sidelining this Queen
entirely allowing the white rook into
the camera yes
so I do want to go over this last game
before I run out of time here this is
why I kind of rushed through that that
previous one and this one was between
the board one for Washington University
who did send a team to this event as
well against F rule Isola Kido who is I
believe the top female player for the
slew team sterilization omastar women's
Grand Master Nicolas is it just a lowly
national master like me so always good
to see some upsets going on between this
wash new team which doesn't have this
huge scholarship program and everything
versus these very well put together
collegiate teams it's good to see a
little bit of competition
going on there so in this game stuff
ruler was in a must-win situation this
was the final round of the tournament
she had to win to win the top female
player prize in this event and so she
chose very combative opening the Kings
Indian defense like we saw in the
previous game and here we see white play
this h3 move but it's going to be very
different circumstances in this case so
white started with a classical London
set up with d4 and Bishop f4 and now why
it simply develops his pieces and ends
up deviating from the classical London
setup by playing this move c4 and this
is a pretty I wouldn't say it's the most
testing approach from white in this case
it's kind of just saying I want to
develop my pieces I'm not going to
commit my pawn to this efore square
creating all these dark squared
weaknesses that we saw in the previous
game I just want my pieces out and I
just want to play chess so real it
chooses Queen e8 which is an interesting
line and at pushing this pawn forward to
e5 next simply develops his Knight to c3
and after e5 Bishop H to Queenie 7 white
gets castled and black plays Knight e8
and I think this was the start of
trouble for black here with this move
Knight e8 so yeah I was about to ask
what do you think the idea is the idea
is of course Mike wants to push this
move f5 but the fact is white hasn't
committed to e4 yet and f5 is going to
come with a lot less tempo a lot less
you know urgency and force and it's
going to be weakening a lot of squares
on this diagonal especially and so what
sticks out to you as some weak squares
in the black camp right now which
squares look like weaknesses there's one
in particular
so II six not yet
not before f5 there's one square that
you kind of just want to you just want
to play play this move because it looks
like the square is a little bit weak
yeah sorry was that yeah
that's exactly right this d5 square so
I'm gonna new to had it as well so the
smooth 95 is going to be very very
important in a lot of these lines and
because of that I think black just needs
to adopt this approach play this move c6
rather than 98 and you can still contest
these squares in the center using this
knight on f6 and you know white might
play rook c1 still go for some idea
involving C 5 flex going to be a little
bit more prepared with this defense of
the d5 square in the game though we saw
98 white does play trick c1 and now
black plays f5 and so I might have
already hinted a little bit at what
white is doing here but what is going to
be the big move for white doesn't have
to be now can it can be later on how is
white going to open things up favorably
for for himself
d take C is certainly one option you're
right in thinking that we need to loosen
up the dark squares right we have this
Bishop stuck on h2 this is going to be
the piece that we're looking to improve
here so the only way we can improve it
is by loosening up softening up this
pawn chain for black so D takes a is one
way of trying to do that I think though
like might be able to just capture back
with the pieces in this case and if you
trade again this bishops not going to
really survive the battle and I'm not
saying this is bad for white I'm just
saying maybe you know maybe this isn't
what he actually wants to be doing c6
still coming yes c5 is exactly right we
want to yeah we want to completely rip
open this diagonal and expose the kind
of disc ordination of the black pieces
for the moment White's much more
prepared to deal with the opening up of
the center as well as this diagonal then
then black is currently and c5 is simply
the way to go about this and white is
simply already winning in this position
black made a couple inaccurate moves
allowing white to break through early on
and Nicholas wastes no time he just
breaks through with c5 and he's entirely
winning here so d take C Knight d5 was
Nick's follow up the best move this
forces this Queen onto this awkward d6
square if you go to a square like this
you're gonna run into these ideas and if
you go to d8 you're simply going to be
losing this pawn like I said opening up
this diagonal with immediate threats so
d6 was the most testing try and Nick
simply followed it up in the best way
Queen b3 getting on this diagonal
forcing King h8 from black which was
played but my arrow keys have failed me
King h8
and now white simply plays rook fd1
bringing this rook opposite this Queen
keeping all of the tension in the center
understanding that you know there's
there's simply nothing really for black
to do here in the game black chose rook
b8 which you know I was looking rough
and rook b8 just a move getting off some
ideas of Knight takes c7 hitting a rook
defending this pawn again but obviously
not the greatest move and then Nick
played a move that I really didn't like
but it was winning so I'll give it to
him he played D takes e5 rather than D
takes e5 I would have much rather
preferred to see him open up this
diagonal this is the diagonal that I
thought was critical for him to open up
but so something like D takes e5 would
have been my choice and there are simply
tactics here sorry and you actually want
to take this with Bishop Bishop takes e5
and now after Queen a3 all of the
Queen's side is is really going to be
falling for 4 black for example a6
Knight takes e5 and you're just getting
demolished on the Queen side well you
don't really have to see that for the
point is both of these moves are good
next move wins so we'll just stick with
it
Knight takes e5 Queen c4 was next idea
and now he's actually swinging this
Queen over to the Kings side c96 Queen
h4
and there's some very nasty threats here
we're lot of time to look at all of them
but things like 97 threatening to take
g6 hitting this Queen this Knight is
defended so very nasty stuff black felt
the need to play g5 just to give himself
some time to deal with this Queen and I
takes g5 was next choice now he takes g5
Queen takes g5
now after c6 97 Queen f6 I see takes
takes and then next big move of the game
to really secure the win here I'll ask
you guys if you can find it
at home or here in the audience what can
you do with white here to really seal
the coffin first of Rila what can be
done
keep in mind there's some dangerous
threats around this black king very
dangerous threats
any ideas
anybody at home nobody at home all right
rook da was Nick Bartkowski choice the
best move in the position attacking this
bishop a second time pinning this knight
to the rook there's nothing that black
can do besides bishop takes a seven but
now after Bishop takes e5 you cannot go
to g8 because Bishop c4 will be
checkmate and if you block with the
knight
I'll take your rook is that true - no if
you block up tonight I'll take your
knight and then take your rook if you
block with the rook I'll take your
Knights and then your bishop and then
your rook and so blacks only choice
Bishop f6 but now after Bishop takes
rook takes rook takes this position is
simply hopeless due to this annoying pin
on the bishop the game did continue as
such but there's simply no way to break
this pin and white just rolled over
black using the extra pawn and what is
essentially just an extra piece the game
continued like this Nick didn't do the
most accurate moves but was more than
enough to get the job done we see like
bring the Queen the King over to the
Queen side trying to break this pin and
eventually does but it's far too late
and Nick ends up winning in this wreck
endgame here
I believe sterilant resigned this
position and so this is a very
impressive game from Nick he simply
outplayed his opponent from the opening
he understood the position better broke
it open when necessary and then found
all the tactics needed to really seal
the deal so any quick questions about
these three games that I went over today
all right well I'll stop taking up all
of Ryan's time for the next class thank
you all for joining me this has been the
Midwest Collegiate Chess Championships
2019 the inaugural year hopefully next
year there will be more teams more
players more exciting chests and more
people watching as well with that in
mind thank you all for coming out this
has been the road to 2000 and I
see you next week
[Music]